Hollywood is full of prejudice bigots
who smell like their own urine firstly
folks I do want to address something
there's a picture circulating around
that supposedly is my wiener and I have
to tell you that I can't say with
certitude that it's not most likely now
it's no secret that I've worked as an
actor and comedian long before I ever
started doing these videos or working
with Fox News and for years I had to
keep my worldview under wraps for fear
of facing anti conservative bias in the
entertainment industry now this week in
the news my friend Benjamin Shapiro has
brought more proof of this to light than
has ever been seen before while writing
his book primetime propaganda Ben
Shapiro actually interviewed network
executives and producers asking them
about anti conservative bias in the
entertainment industry and the results
are pretty shocked and you've seen a lot
of the audio or heard it all over the
news and and seen it on the internet
recently but um here's a newer more
exclusive always damning clip just for
you
you
one of the things that I've been
investigating is that there's several
you know kind of outside criticisms of
Hollywood from the general society one
of them from the people on more
right-wing side of the aisle is that the
vast majority of executives and creators
in the television business tend to be
politically left and so that kind of
political bias combined with the kind of
quick ashiness that dominates every
business means that is very difficult
for people who are politically
conservative to usually don't do this
because everyone hates a whiner and
nobody owes me anything I understand
that but I do want to show you this a
while back my manager had been in
contact with some producers at The Daily
Show with Jon Stewart longtime comedian
worked with news and political
commentary seems like the fit here's
what they send back but now listen I
know that many of you may think that I
suck as a comedian and at everything I
do and you may be right
but what's most unnerving about this
email is that the producer acknowledges
that steven is a talented guy but that
they never book conservative pundits see
their selection process is not entirely
based on merit but on excluding specific
points of view now clearly I think that
that's wrong but what do you think in
the meantime let's listen know what Ben
thinks so folks I have Benjamin Shapiro
on the line here
via Skype and want to apologize I look
like a bum Ben actually had to
reschedule our interview last minute
because he had something to do with CNN
so I had to run back from the gym Ben
for future reference that kind of
business may work with CNN but here were
professionals yeah yeah
moving forward Ben um this is obviously
something I've run into a lot and that's
why I was very interested in your book
um but what inspired you to write
primetime propaganda well actually I
wanted to write a book about Obama and
the publisher approached me and said why
write a book about Hollywood I said well
you know you pay me I'll do it so but
you know I've been in Hollywood my
entire life my parents are both they
both work in the industry my mom does a
reality TV business development my dad
writes film and TV scoring and so I
decided that you know I have a lot of
friends in this industry many of whom
can't get work because they're
conservative and it was worthwhile going
undercover a little bit and just
exposing what was going on now I'm big
criticism of conservatives is that well
you're just whining this isn't really
true there is no anti conservative bias
or bigotry really um what do you say to
that
I mean it's utter crap in fact there's
there's some talk in town about us
filing a class-action lawsuit against
some of the studios and networks because
of this I mean the people I have people
on tape admitting to the fact that there
is discrimination in the business and
that they're actually happy there was
discrimination in the business right
well I just played that tape and and I
sent you the email that I had received
that we were when we were doing with Jon
Stewart how do you think actors should
move forward conservatives in Hollywood
what's the best thing they can do to
help out with this cause or even to
harborage everyday non Hollywood
conservative I mean I think the average
everyday not Hollywood conservative can
start by voicing support for the
Conservatives in Hollywood who can't
work I think that we also need to
approach the advertisers who have been
utterly bamboozled by the television
industry into thinking that the only
viewers that matter our liberal viewers
which is utterly untrue it's false and
it's and it's terrible but beyond that
look people in the industry are gonna
need to start filing some lawsuits now
you use a brilliant analogy you talked
about a landlord wanting to rent out an
apartment to tennis could you use that
for us here I think it's effective yeah
I mean
yeah here's the way that it works I mean
in Hollywood they're not gonna tell you
they're not hiring you because you're
conservative it's just not gonna happen
they're gonna make up any other excuse
if you're a black guy and you want to
move into an apartment building and they
don't take black people they don't tell
you we're not taking you because black
they tell you we're not taking you
because you know we have income
requirements because you have too many
people in your family we don't allow
pets right any excuse except the one
that really it's about the same thing
holds true in Hollywood it'll be all
your writing just doesn't fit your
acting man that's so much right they'll
make up any excuse except the one that
really matters which is you're
conservative right except your case
apparently we're I mean I looked at your
case and it's like them actually coming
out and saying Steven you're black we're
not hiring you you know I face that kind
of prejudice as a black man in America
every day so if only could feel my pain
but then we do appreciate it
thanks for all the work that you're
doing with a you know primetime
propaganda do a bunch of work on your
site and I think this is an issue that
definitely needs some awareness raised
in the public eye so appreciate it
look forward working with you soon you
know what I'll give you a call on
Saturday
ion's you Saturday Steven and Jewish is
the Sabbath you're Jewish yeah yeah I
don't really do Jewish yeah